hey everybody Deadpool 2 is now in
theaters and we are here with our
in-depth spoiler review did cable Domino
Peter and the other newcomers to the
sequel help it rise above the very high
bar set by the first movie in 2016 we're
gonna talk all about dead-ball - we're
also gonna get into a lot of other stuff
that is not Deadpool related if you're
like where's Eric
I don't like this if it's not Eric he's
on vacation oh oh no I'm not killed in
Bahasa he went on vacation just let him
have this he works really hard so we
also are going to talk about I think the
ending the shocking twists in the movie
like I said it's spoilers but before we
get into that how about everybody
introduce themselves with new rock stars
news host no it's me Sam basher how's
everyone doing hi Aaron hi then your
name
oh I'm Tommy Bechtold great mr. Malina
yeah I don't feel so good okay well yeah
a couple weeks late on that no when we
take them seriously you're not welcome
but let's get into it so the highs and
lows of the sequels was crazy
Deadpool - Deadpool - miss Bergen Braun
we paid for your ticket and you spend it
on book club they said see the most
violent movie in theaters okay how about
we're gonna do a Deadpool 2 review you
can give your same criticisms that are
for book club just say Deadpool - it was
crazy
to get this back on track as I've
already off we're gonna dive into the
deeper reasons hopefully why this film
worked and why it came up short in some
ways we'll get to those again this
discussion includes spoilers so be
warned if you haven't seen this movie
yet you can watch Sam's spoiler free
review doesn't need to fuse anyway hey
hey then go up the movie and then meet
us back here he's not the one that like
gets the views it's it's you guys you
have watch so let's start specifically
with the elements we liked what worked
really well in specifically Deadpool -
Tommy okay so first of all I thought the
choice of books they all read was
I'm Sam I will say that this movie does
a lot better on the second watch is well
liked the first watch is obviously
really good but the second one you start
to really you like you know what some of
the secret jokes are gonna be so you
kind of pay attention to a lot of the
other stuff that's hidden throughout the
movie because movie is packed with
Easter eggs but besides that this movie
while it's hilarious and the actions
amazing because they had leech half of
John wick there's a great joke about
that he he does a great job with the
action but also the writing especially
of an SN Wade's relationship and his
name is Russell in the movie Russell and
Wade's relationship the way that kind of
mirrors cable and his daughter and what
cables mission is it's impressive of how
deep this movie actually is even though
you could say it doesn't need to be but
it's the reason why I think the first
I'd pull did really well was that you're
actually invested weirdly in this like
testicle looking man there's like
struggles with cancer honestly and like
his like pain of like thinking he was
gonna die and then his torture and if
that really worked in the first movie so
bringing that over is definitely no it
they just change it up a little bit they
just take a different angle of yeah and
the way they're able to parallel cable
story with Wade's and the way they're
able to intersect they have more in
common than they really like you can
make eye contact about how they have
stuff in common and you almost think
like oh is he gonna mess it up with like
a joke or something any kind of doesn't
he just think in the first movie they
spend a lot of time like he's the
character like it's all about Deadpool
and his quips and I feel like he's
bouncing off himself yes he has good
moments with TJ miller's character and
like in the cab and there was like you
know back and forth but it was from all
him he was driving all the jokes it was
him and his internal dialogue now he put
him with the team he can bounce off
people and i actually preferred like him
in Russell or hem in Domino too so it's
like you know you have contradicting and
contrasting characters that are just
having this epic dialogue and I prefer
that back-and-forth than just him kind
of being the the joke after joke after
joke that I'm surprised that they got so
many insular and fueler comic-book jokes
like really in jokes they make a joke
like yeah he was like he
Domino's power sounds like someone who
is coked up in the 80s who can't drop
feet it's like this really specific look
it up Rafi they're like this is the only
way they all come to a point I only see
the movie once I was here twice I don't
have the the in-depth maybe perspective
but I thought they use the music in the
fight scenes I was think the music Tommy
are you talking about book club or that
book so like the rap songs mean no all
right funny which has a joke in it that
like is like subtle right what a way to
make a living yeah this is his job it's
like funny but it's also like it's
really catchy like it's like perfect top
40 radio which is there was I think
expert way to score or have a soundtrack
for Deadpool you think Dolly Parton is
currently in the top 40 that's great
though yeah the they're like purposely
re they like did that in the first movie
but they kind of like just reinvented
how action scenes can work and then the
juggernut song that was set to a chorus
where you have to wait to the very end
of the movie even though there's no like
post post post credit scene yeah that
song was worth waiting yes to hear the
words of it yeah cuz when when they're
just going through and one of the final
segments and hearing the song that was
funny enough but then when they play it
completely uninterrupted it was amazing
so lot of the feedback that the movie is
getting is that this movie is on par
with the first some people saying it's a
little bit better some people saying
it's not as good as the first where do
you guys stand with that well real quick
I haven't said like what I liked about
it but I'll use it as a transition to to
that I think that the movie I think they
do need those moments with
him and Vanessa otherwise I think it
would it would be like why do I care
about anything that's happening right
now but I'll say that action-wise it is
on par and in some ways you could tell
that they're like they actually like
under they opened the marble vault and
they're like here's our real budget and
like this is how Marvel movies should
look and there was a lot more action a
lot more going on so I felt like that
was a step up in some ways I say what
was a step down is the creativity that
they had with like we don't we don't
have budget on the first one so we're
gonna do this highway thing like in
every twisted way we can just to make it
like fascinating and this one like once
it they do have the budget it's like
let's do the thing on the highway where
they're trying to get the prisoner who's
in the caravan it's like yeah we've seem
to make it a little less creative in
that but also the moments with Domino
kind of made up for that yeah I thought
those are like Rube Goldberg Styles like
killing that's fascinating that's very
creative so I feel like those things are
on the way up from the last one I'll say
what was on the way down a little bit to
transition over to what issues we had
and whether or not you thought this was
better than the last one for me there's
a couple but the the two that really
stand out is one I like hate to admit it
but I think the jokes success rate is
significantly lower than in the first
one where the first one had a pretty
high average but I also think it's
because they took less swings at bat you
know they were like you know what I got
a perfect joke here I'm gonna say it
this one was more like the comic where
it's like Deadpool is just kind of every
single line he says it's a joke and in
the comic he's not that funny
no I because in fact all the characters
is always annoyed by him because they're
like you only say these things that
don't matter so I think they took more
swings which meant they had more misses
and the other thing is they really try
to get emotional there at one point and
it was so late in the film that I kind
of feel like you kind of you you have to
either either commit to like sometimes
Deadpool really does care about things
and that's a rhythm we can get used to
of him caring or he never does because
instead I love you guys you felt this
but there was a rhythm of like he's
always gonna be a smartass he's always
not gonna
care and then at the end when it's like
you know when he's dying and also things
with Vanessa you kind of had this like
feeling like he's about to make a quip
isn't he he's about to like undercut
this moment yeah and it kept feeling
like that was about to happen and then
it didn't sometimes and instead of
feeling like Oh cuz it matters it felt a
little bit like oh because they chose
like well this something needs to matter
to him and it felt like a little too
little too late so there's two things
the humors a little below and I think
that uh the the heart moments only kind
of work like they weren't earned or they
or they felt like shoehorned alone they
felt like a requirement in order because
they knew like we need to give him
something he cares about and I don't
think they served it up in an organic
like authentic way of like he actually
the only thing I buy is that he actually
loves Vanessa which should be enough but
a lot of the movie is about how much he
cares about the kid and that seems kind
of like actually not because I had the
chance to see this twice the second
viewing kind of helps hum Obrecht it
does kind of help streamline this
because I was on the same page with you
after the first thing I was like the
emotional beats I'm a sucker for any
like good slow slow down version of a
pop song so uh take on me comes I'm like
sweating but no AAA so it did get to me
but on the second viewing you kind of
see there's more of a through-line
happening throughout the movie and
actually the use of music does a really
good job of kind of giving the cues of
win like maybe there's an internal
struggle going on for Wade we're like
especially during the prison scene where
you can see that like he's trying to
push
Russell away from him so he's like they
don't have like he doesn't want you
please his real name's Ricky bacon Ricky
Baker
sorry Ricky Baker I can't do it I'm
sorry I'm sorry
but it does kind of I
out it kind of irons out some of those
problems unless it doesn't like it but
for me it did but I just wanted to put
that out yeah I don't love when they
solve a with post-production though do
you know I mean like I wanted to be
there and in the shoot that's fair yeah
that makes sense I I didn't love I
really liked the movie I think I was
telling you before we started filming I
wasn't a super fan of the first one I
liked it a lot but I think it wasn't
that excited I liked it when I I mean I
just wasn't that like pumped for it to
come out and I wasn't huge fan of the
comic so like what I saw I was
pleasantly surprised how much I liked
the first one and I liked this one as
well but I did think like after a while
it wears down on you when he's
commenting so much on the quality of the
movie like when he's like and now an
overblown CGI fight you're like okay but
I think they put those jokes in because
they're more digestible for an audience
of non comic-book fans and I thought
there were a lot more of those jokes
that were like oh this is a joke for
like everyone not necessarily people who
like know the inside and out of comic
books or even just like the cartoons or
anything of these characters so I
thought there was a little joking
broadened out a little bit in this movie
too as well
they were so funny but I agree
definitely with your point float that
there was a lot more they they they
definitely made a lot more jokes that
didn't land as hard in this one yeah
like the first one I was da egg I felt
like I had to like watch the movie
multiple times so I could catch it you
know and then you'd still be laughing at
the same jokes and you're missing a joke
in the background
I agree but uh no you guys are both
right my sentiment was laughing everyone
was like how down for a good time yeah I
kind of heard that though but I felt
like there was a little bit of like we
like this new movie about Capitan we're
like everyone's like they have to go
whoa something that you said something
that wipes his faces money they pointed
out though I think is introduced to
things actually
the calling out the film itself so in
the first movie there's a lot of like
calling out the superhero genre and the
flaws within it and that's very fun I
think we all reacted to that and this
one it has those jokes and then it also
has jokes about this movie it's
health being bad like multiple times he
makes a joke of lazy writing but also
it's kind of like yeah that is there's a
steaming pile of foreshadowing yeah and
it really undercut kind of that moment
so it's weird when they turned it
against themselves instead of being like
yeah maybe don't have lazy writing mitt
like maybe call out a different movie
that lazy lazy writing but another thing
that I think is why this movie might hit
people a little differently than the
first one again to be clear we're in the
section where we were planting grapes
which is the only reason we're being
negative I think but I think overall
what's happening what's gonna happen
culturally five out of me what's
happening culturally is the last movie
came out right before Batman V Superman
and we had been inundated with those ads
at that time and we were just like oh
man this looks like gonna be really dark
and right before it comes out Deadpool
comes out and is like forget that like
that is so stupid to take that this
seriously and so it was like the perfect
timing and now swing over to here we're
in a very similar situation but instead
of the dark DC movie we just had a very
dark Marvel movie and we're all like
wait no but we are the kind of really
taking this seriously I'm really sad and
now trying to make art these movie
stupid and it's like kind of but also my
friends are dead I think it does a good
job though with its emotional beats to
kind of bring it back down even though
they have the jokes they can make fun of
it also way more just insular Marvel
comic book jokes but also MCU jokes
they're like winners hold your arm they
mention that there's a lot of jokes
about dubstep and I feel like we're like
six years too late like three things one
people are gonna have to Google does the
videos like an added yeah yeah cuz like
they've made that joke and they're like
crap like I don't think I've listened to
like they played Skrillex no it's like
oh yeah
I don't like dub I used to like dubstep
but I don't anymore but uh overall I'm
okay with those fourth wall breaking
jokes but you're definitely right that
sometimes you're like sitting there I
know I'm supposed to laugh but I'm like
this movie feels like two hours yes it
feels like it so it's a little bit like
oh we didn't need a list of three every
time you go to make a joke just the top
one they
actually in the even I just remembered
that they even copied the first one even
more because I had that we were talking
before this that's that both movies are
pretty similar I know you had like an
analogy for it but there's even like a
point when I'm in the first movie what
was the main villain Francis when he he
stabs Wade in the head and then like it
music gets all romantic and he starts
like hallucinating with the little
unicorn the the part yeah and in this
movie same thing happened with but
Colossus is the one that came and like
saving which was great but I'm like I'm
just realizing how I'm similar PG movies
which again is it man if it's not broken
yeah and then just so as we wrap up I
want to get back on the positive train
for a second just because we're leaving
out we barely discussed this and it's so
important I think the addition of Domino
and cable to this universe is like so
worthwhile and real quick also one of
the best scenes in any superhero movie
recently is the the launching of the
x-force into into the real world and
they all are immediately killed you can
feel it though but it also it's that's
one of the even though this joke does
the this movie takes a lot of jokes and
they don't always hit it that is such a
great payoff like not a wind advisory
there's a way there's a wind advisory in
all these movies they skydive but
there's a chance I will say there's a
chance bedlam is not dead because
there's a woman but he's probably dead
like shining star Vanisher that was a
great which f you caught that cameo
it'll be in the breakdown if he didn't
well actually found out how they did
that or someone mentioned someone has a
theory that David Leitch because he and
the co-director for John wick were both
stunt people individuals and each was
Brad Pitt's stunt double for a couple
movies so they're friends also really
quick when cable does his time jump to
the past those two random people who are
obviously makeup all right you're like
was clearly alan tudyk the other one is
in a lot of makeup who is a lot a so he
also had a cameo in an MC movie that
came out last
year starring Chris Hemsworth remember
there were three cameos yes a lot of
people caught it online I'm like that I
could not tell I was trying to like take
off the makeup in my head for two
viewings I still couldn't figure out
people were saying that's Matt Damon
Allen - look right there which is like
do a full MCU or Marvel movie but cable
and Domino real quickly give them their
do what the the heaviest moment I ever
noticed the CGI was Domino's like first
like the the car crash scene which is
not not knocking it's awesome but I
really enjoyed her taking down the
pedophiles and that in the ordinary but
like that was such a cool way of showing
luck in a more grounded way that felt
more true to how david leitch could
direct it was like yeah do hand-to-hand
combat but it's like she's basically
just taking all the luck out of the room
and they're just they're getting every
bout of everything they could yes more I
cannon in those things I can give you
the worst loss yes absolutely I feel
like with her and her powers it's so
refreshing in in the superhero genre we
haven't really seen anything like this
and like we have we have seen how many
heroes in the last infinity war like we
arrived we are seeing so many different
powers thrown at us all the time but
this one for me was super refreshing
because it kind of challenged you in a
way where it's not Duane bam thank you
ma'am
it was like wow it's actually really
really clever yeah I think it actually
sets up a really interesting sequel
thing with her but I'll bring that up
later mordom in kids tell me I was
surprised yes like Josh Brolin obviously
was gonna kill it but also I enjoy oh I
love the design of his time slider like
little dears that was really cool it was
super cool and the way he would
interface with technology was like
here's a quick we're getting a quick
idea of like what his powers are it's
like something probably telekinetic we
didn't have any telepathy or anything
like that that's fine you don't need to
add the whole gambit of powers to him
but also it's like he's very capable of
making weapons tabor Garrett's cameo was
awesome you couldn't tell he was also in
maker Cable Domino final thoughts yeah
oh okay it's why what was I gonna say
forget I like cable the way that his
personality unfolded gradually from like
killing machine when he was first
introduced who's like basically t1000
like comes down travels to time wants to
kill the kid and then by the end you
find out why any even starts getting in
on the like the quip game with everybody
cuz it's like okay if he's gonna be part
of this universe in future movies which
I think obviously they've set up that he
will be he has to like play along with
the genre of the movie so I like that
they didn't just have him immediately
start like firing back Barb's at
Deadpool that at first he was kind of
this like literally robotic killing
machine and then very gradually
developed in really clever and not like
I don't think it was a rushed payoff for
that at all okay Josh Brolin can do no
wrong I feel like he's at a point in his
career where he like avoided the
superhero genre for so long and then his
eye alright I'm all in and I run out of
all for the money and he's just I
honestly like the less you care the
better it is and I feel like that's
what's happening he's just like all my
friends are doing it is what I told him
about for infinity war he's like I'm
working with all the people that I've
worked with before and everyone's in you
know this movie and this is where it's
at at the moment so let's dive in and do
it that's you can kind of just tell and
he's just like gloves off like let's do
it and I he was so great in for newborn
he's so great and so different in this
and you like he's such a good actor and
he's just bringing it I like that he's
also like he's he's 50 or pushing like
in the mid 50s but he like he's very
physical with his action which I thought
was really cool the way they realized a
lot of his like physical attributes were
really cool and the way that was at
least the obviously heightened most like
pract like practical effects with visual
effects but that looked for the most
part a lot like the right to call makeup
on his chest which is really cool and
I'm excited for more I want to I want
them to kind of dive into they didn't
even explain like what's happening but
you're like lines from the future how
did Josh Brolin lose his arm and how
convenient was that for the movie let us
know how you think he lost his arm in
the comments below
so let you thought about Deadpool - I
check out our other videos breaking down
the movies post-credit scenes and
obviously be on the lookout for an
entire full movie breakdown because they
snuck in a lot of Easter eggs that are
too like obscure comics but then also of
course - the entire world of pop culture
so you'll just have to look up at that
pond the next week what we do have
though is a trivia question for everyone
so if you guys can have your tiny
versions of cards whoa don't judge them
it's how you use the card we are going
to ask a trivia question the winner of
the trivia question will get to I think
deliver the news stories at the end whoa
I don't like that buy thing but anyway
and then the loser is going to have to
do something very difficult at the end
of this show but here's our trivia
question are you guys ready yeah all
right you can play along in the comments
below and we'll just have to trust that
you didn't skip to the end of the
episode or Google it all right
in Deadpool 2 negasonic teenage warhead
is referred to by nicknames like Justin
Bieber and 11 what is the first nickname
we hear deadpool call her in the first
deadpool movie and we're back i got
permanent marker all over my hand
we got a trivia question answers in you
can enter them in the comments below but
let's go ahead and move on in the
meantime we're going to do a quick
update on a flash news story that's not
like it's gonna be what the flash
bridesmaid we're just gonna talk about
it very quick it's about Star Wars
actually jon favreau we all know is
doing a TV series but we just found out
a little bit more about it it's actually
gonna be a live-action TV series set
between the events of Return of the Jedi
and the force awakens nice because I
mean it there's a chunk of time there so
that makes sense is this gonna be on
like ABC or yeah hopefully so there's a
30 year gap there after the battle
Battle of Endor and then the first
orders devastation posny and prime so a
lot of the legends novels actually take
place during that time including
aftermath which the ones that they are
released right before the movie but then
that's not like yeah all the new sir
yeah the new books are those are not
legend dude I got this one from here so
obviously when they wiped the slate and
they started up all new novels for canon
yeah it all takes place basically as
soon as the Death Star blows up and the
aftermath of what that meant for the
Empire so it's the shift their lost ours
is my favorite one it's by Claude it
written by Claudia gray Webb story it is
a love story it's a bit of a Romeo and
Juliet but it's between a tie file it
from the Empire and someone who actually
defects and goes over to the rebellion
so there's a lot happening there and I'm
wondering which one they're going to do
or if they're gonna actually take on a
whole new story we'll have to watch and
see which ones I do also if they do
actual legends books too because there's
also other good stories they could take
from there Jeannette but moving on to
more Deadpool alright everybody so with
Deadpool to now in the world and out
there a lot of people are talking about
the way that the movie ends and those
really amazing post-credit sequences
Eric actually already made a breakdown
of those things that you definitely go
check out but here we're gonna talk
about the way that Deadpool twos ending
sets up a potential situation for the
upcoming Deadpool sequels and where we
think that might go so is there a
Deadpool trilogy or even more how will
Domino or cable play into it
let us know you guys thoughts obviously
depends on how much money that maybe
makes its gonna make enough money or at
least Drew Goddard x-force movie because
that's what they're definitely setting a
good but it I'm gonna be bummed if Peter
doesn't show up for just like I say like
maybe the guy in the chair we set up
that joke in spider-man homecoming it's
a guy in the chair Peter gets to do that
or at least he gets he brings brownies
for everybody changes he's a villain I
wouldn't be so good a lot of people
thought he was gonna be Pete wisdom from
the comics who's he's not that know so
much better it's so much better these
not so he's a guy who can like shoot
laser knives out of his fingers
I don't want that for a beater though
this Twitter is amazing I just want that
life for him there's no way they're not
making a Deadpool 3 also though like
that me I don't know if they'll make
more than that because I don't think
anyone's gonna play Deadpool besides
Ryan Reynolds it's not I mean for a long
time unless they introduced some sort of
strange spin-off but like I think that
they'll make three and they definitely
make x-force and then pivot and they
talked about or ryan reynolds mentioned
that in a third deadpool movie if it
happened like hypothetically that he'd
want it to be smaller than this like
because this is pretty this is big
there's a lot of people now you're yeah
luckily they killed off so many but
talking about the characters that are
still there we still have Domino we have
negasonic teenage warhead we have Yuki
ho now we have fire fist and call Peter
so which of these characters do we
expect to definitely return you Colossus
you grated they feel like they were
setting that up honestly I think the one
that could carry and pivot like if they
were to focus on and want a character
and like give Ryan Reynolds a break
Dominic I think that that's a lot
fledged out there and I think that she
could really carry the franchise with a
lot of people like asking for more
female centric like superhero movies
Domino would be a really smart decision
like it cuz you could also like you
could take some of the like strong
female characters already have like
negasonic and longest name ever and
Yukio but you could also take in
everybody else like the eques didn't
even mention by the x-men little cameo
was amazing in this movie so you could
maybe even borrow some characters from
there it wouldn't it wouldn't be a bad
idea
when my favorite idea is that I was just
sitting there in in watching Deadpool 2
and I was thinking you know Domino it
seems unstoppable and I think that
actually that'd be an interesting thing
to portray in the next movie
she also in a way can really do Deadpool
and that she can't really die either at
least not but if it's not by her own
choosing right like if she doesn't well
if she wants to make it out of a
situation
she will every single time so I was like
how do we actually follow that thread
and figure out what is her worst case
scenario so that she does maybe die and
just my Brian my Brian
guy named Brian in here like black tile
and he thinks for me but he he told me
in my head um that I'm a bad boy you're
never gonna make it your family but he
also told me what about the idea of
Domino set up in a situation where it
actually would be better for her to die
or a situation where it's more lucky for
her to let someone she cares about a lot
where the world would be better off if
she died or just like if I'm gonna I'm
not gonna die instantly or I'm gonna be
a burn victim and have to suffer a lot
of pain or divert like there are
scenarios where it'd be luckier to just
die or it'd be luckier for instance if
it's between her and her her girlfriend
or boyfriend or something like that and
like it's more lucky for her for them to
die there's just ways to like make it a
very dark situation for you you have to
find her kryptonite because that's what
is it that could bring her down and I
think that's an interesting part it
doesn't becomes more from right but yeah
I think you know finding if I could dude
the rocks I was like hi I'm probability
well in comics it's usually never just
like everything happens and it's good
for her it's always just at the last
second it's like and she falls out of a
car she doesn't die but she breaks her
arm and so it's it's luck but it's not
like wish-granting so I hear he kind of
felt like it was yeah but like you could
dial it back a little bit which wouldn't
hurt this movie in any way it's just
like no it doesn't doesn't mean
everything works out it's like I'm still
gonna get hit I'm still gonna maybe get
shot but that I can still survive and I
can still help get through it yeah yeah
do you think she was a bit overpowered
or was capable more of a power cable is
not very overpowered I thing on some
ways I felt like they held back on what
cable could do Domino's definitely
technically overpowered but it worked
out in the movie because she wasn't the
main protagonist but it would be
interesting in her own movie really
quick about cable though for those that
read the comics obviously cable and
Deadpool have a lot of story that could
be told there do you guys think that's
gonna be in sequels I wonder that the
the other scenario I thought because
yeah they could do so much with that but
I also thought now they could have used
this movie as a way to just introduce
him into the x-men universe now yes he
is you know Scott Summers son so it's
like they could have he could appear in
what is it Dark Phoenix which is done
shooting but he already shot scenes for
that the people don't know about
yes he's now introduced in this movie
and it would kind of make that totally
unless I mean it would really shoot
rather him be and that's a situation
where he fits a little bit for me that's
like a selfish thing well he's a great
character in that whole story oh yeah
yeah I understand why people would want
him in Deadpool movies but like it
definitely takes away from the insanity
of Deadpool if cables there which is
maybe not a bad thing but if people like
the like silliness of the movies cable
is a downer
I like the buddy cop I want another
buddy cop thing yeah or Sonia but I'll
try to have sex with Sansa like so if it
comes to Sansa Stark it's the same thing
as Jon Snow and it's no condoms ever
[Laughter]
we'll just cut this out well yeah you're
right we can usually against you in a
court of law those sound like our
prediction so let us know what you guys
have is predictions for the behavior in
a way for size that's my prediction in
the comments below just fill it with
ideas for Deadpool 3 and so on and so on
all right but also it's time for another
quick news update it's the other big
news I thought of this week marblehead
Kevin Feige he revealed that along with
Captain Marvel the MCU is now definitely
gonna introduce the character Kamala
Khan miss Marvel so Khan is actually a
Pakistani American teen who would be the
first Muslim American movie superhero I
don't know if you saw on Twitter actors
Riz Ahmed
that's right the others he said to Mindy
Kaling and Kumail Nanjiani I that hey
what are we gonna be in this movie let's
get the script yeah they want to write
script I just think that'd be amazing
honestly like especially like the cast
that he already started to line up so
just really excited about that maybe
keep a lookout for maybe a little more
about who miss Marvel is in this channel
all right everybody this week comedian
and nerd guru Patton Oswalt posted a
very fascinating theory about the origin
of the Joker the version portrayed by
Heath Ledger in the Dark Knight a ton of
you guys saw this so Ledger's Joker
famously has no origin he tells a lot of
conflicting stories of his past in the
movie and everyone has their own theory
of which one's real but a lot of people
recently have started to think that
maybe he's actually a soldier who is
suffering from PTSD he does make a
specific reference to a lot of soldiers
being killed and like a truck explosion
but now Patton Oswalt has added a lot on
to this idea if instead of a just
general soldier he's actually a military
intelligence officer and the reason he
was able to kind of figure this out is
he was taking a look at that
interrogation scene between him and
Batman and he's using a lot of kind of
CIA mastery of interrogation techniques
so specifically there are moments where
you notice that he when he's with he's
talking about knowing the squealers and
then when he sees them it's almost he's
been trained to identify the people that
would speak to the CIA or be potentially
like for instance if he's in Iraq people
that might switch on their side and be
able to leak information to him but also
uses a specific CIA tactic called
reversal and it's when he's directing
Batman in their own scene with each
other he actually is controlling the
conversation he's walking him through
the steps that he is he specifically
says never start with the head the
victim gets all fuzzy kind of a
reference to the way that he's done his
own interrogations so I guess that could
be a origin story for this version of
the Joker not the Joker just in general
we have lots of different takes on that
so just wonder what you guys think do
you guys think that this makes sense for
specifically the Joker in the Dark
Knight that he worked in the CIA as
he's smart he's so smart and he has like
a lot of knowledge on the subject and
like the power of manipulation comes
from being able to understand people in
a psychological sense and you know I
think that's that just makes sense and
also you might know how got these scars
what if he pulled the pin from a grenade
what I also think is roughly what his
estimated age would be in the movie that
type of like psychosis and depth would
indicate someone who's lived a lot of
life in a few years so like something
like being in the military he's still a
young man right yeah I don't know but
yeah I mean he probably was was very
young yeah yeah and I think the
character doesn't come across as like a
man any older than 30 so what could have
turned him so bad unless he started as a
psychopath right you know from there but
no that's actually a really cool that is
a really that's almost a perfect way to
ground the Joker to be a good foil for
Batman because Batman like you he can
take on a common crook a common thief
because that's not he's not really
dealing with the psychological aspects
of that person he's just punching them
in right and that's if you really want
to dive into that that's awful but like
when it comes to the Joker you need
someone who is 50 steps ahead of Batman
and not just in the sense of like that's
just a throwaway line you always hear
like oh he just must be so smart it's
like no he knows who this person is and
he doesn't know exactly as soon as they
walk in the room he can just ask the
specific like three questions that he
needs and he can he can immediately
pinpoint what kind of person
Batman is who Bruce Wayne is right know
how to play the game how to manipulate
him exactly as needed and actually yeah
like who else could keep up with Batman
unless someone specifically trained in
these like mental games yeah like comic
books are fun because you can be like
wow he's crazy and so he's like super
sane or he sees me for saying yeah he
like he has like he sees reality from a
different point of view it's like okay
let's try to tell story that everyone
can like get on board with and then you
pick something that we can actually
somewhat grasp and it's someone who is
trained to many people and manipulate
them all right that's Batman's like
weakness
when you think about it he's got all the
gear and gadgets he's got the physical
strength he's got the brute force BAM
you know he's a detective so we can read
clues but clues are usually not
emotional clothes our physical clues so
here it's all in the head and I don't
think that's where Bruce actually has
figured it out completely and so I think
yeah Joker can just come here in just
like I can read you like a book and I
can literally make your mind putty right
yeah so maybe a psychiatrist would also
be an interesting potential origin I'll
but up but if you throw in the fact that
he knows his way around military
hardware - yeah it does make sense it's
deadly you comes from there all right
all right I think that's a very
fascinating thing that works
specifically also you okay I was also
taking the question over to the other
Tommy there okay I said my thing I'm
very happy with what I said comment
below if you're also happy I just think
it makes perfect sense for specifically
the nolan version not for really any
others because no one needed to ground
everyone in his movies but moving on
it's very exciting because it's we got
these from you guys by tweeting at new
rock stars every friday we open it up to
you guys to ask us questions directly
but we don't get to prepare so we just
throw these out of people we team up
them at them like quick lightning yeah
baby
if Deadpool interviewed you for his
super duper f group of what would you
say is your superpower oh wow BC oh I
asking mommy and daddy to pay my cell
phone bill
I'll get everyone's cell phone bills
paid those at Gua Gua ubc Wow Wow BC
okay great question glad we see also
like I would just be like real good at
kicking - kicking in cell phone pills
would this is from at nerd pepper would
you choose to be at Xavier school for
gifted students or at Hogwarts for one
school term can I get Hogwarts I go with
xav crazy I want to be Nessman do you
have mutant powers no but I'm not a
wizard either so both are not going to
be going you get your own question we're
sorry about Hogwarts actually from at
Kenzi hagedorn our friend which Hogwarts
houses do you think the original
Avengers are each end like the original
Avengers why Thor is 100%
oh yeah you tell me we do or there's and
an Iron Man a Slytherin Hawkeye is
ravenclaw Black Widow
she's ravenclaw mm-hmm America uh Hulk
is he's a little puppet it's just what a
temper in a temper he's either high
Gryffindor / Slytherin I think so that
he's green and Captain America
hufflepuff great white but Bruce Ghana
is revving claw oh that's bender
Hufflepuff e's a stickler for the rules
he's also he's brave he's from at dks
underscore film school if you could
transfer one character from Marvel or DC
to the other universe who would one
character one to the other
okay Marvel needs better villains I feel
like oh man the Joker in Marvel would be
chaotic and kill people for real but
working together that'd be interesting
uh oh man but can you imagine if you
just like threw like Superman into into
marble
[Music]
kicking alright let's go ahead and move
on to our next segment in the pipeline
the videos coming out this week we got
some secret ones that we're still
working on but the ones that we can talk
about the very obvious ones we have a
Deadpool Easter egg breakdown coming out
of another Deadpool video you'll see
what it is I'll soon and then obviously
guys it's almost solo times alright so
keep a look out for their life yeah but
before we get to our trivia answers we
all get our 15 seconds shoutouts so
let's go ahead and start with our guest
for the week Tommy hi shouldn't be
permanent host Tommy vegetable here I
guess my shoutout is to this next
Tuesday will be the final episode of
ABC's the middle it's been on for nine
seasons and they're ending the run after
a triumphant run five years ago they
made one of the best decisions of their
lives and inserted me into their show so
that has been a pleasure and I'm very
proud of being a part of that show but
also the bigger show is impressive in
its own right so check out the final
episode of that at 8:30 p.m. on Tuesday
I'm not about you got the middle of you
Brian I mean I could have just taken one
but I was very mod over watch they are
doing a really cool charity thing with
mercy so you can actually buy the pink
skin for mercy video games guys and all
the proceeds go to breast cancer but if
you're not into video games check out
this one is from Black Milk we're doing
a second labyrinth range and I've got
one with Ludo on it one with the little
worm that says la did you say hello
no la but that's close enough you know
all the ones from the labyrinth you know
there may be guys 11 say it with me on
three one two three
Oh del Toro's masterpiece Pan's
Labyrinth anyway
black milks of Brisbane label where I'm
from in Australia such you do God do
what stop it no waiting 15 seconds Sam
you put in seconds how about I finally
checked out season 2 of the series of
unfortunate events and this is a very
strange show where I enjoy it but also
Wednesday I'm confused it's not a home
run but I do enjoy it so if you like the
books you're the only audience they're
gonna like that TV show go check it out
me and my 15 seconds shout out goes to
Barry on HBO watch that show it's Bill
hader's new show but it's also by Alec
Berg who does Silicon Valley alright it
does want to be like if you didn't get
don't get on board in the first two
episodes it's not one of those ones
where it's like give it five it's more
just know that the show like it changes
what comedy can be as a sitcom or
whatever it's very inconsistent with its
tone but in a way that you're like yeah
this is real and it's so good yeah check
out Barry you know what let's move on to
our trivia question so we're going to
hand out our previous answers and we're
gonna read each other's answers if you
need a reminder of what the trivia
question is gonna be the big reveal here
in Deadpool 2 negasonic teenage warhead
is referred to by nicknames like Justin
Bieber and 11 what is the first nickname
we hear Deadpool call her in the first
Deadpool movie this is negasonic teenage
warhead to remind you Sam mod wrote
Sinead O'Connor's junaid well you're
gonna go ahead and read my answer
because it's the same one but I wrote it
the wrong way
alright Santosh to NATO Connor NATO
Connor did you eliminate but Sinead Sam
wrote Sinead O'Connor don't pretend like
this is the not a dumb name it's si
she's on see Tommy Sinead O'Connor stuff
there's a debate about who got a more
right will hope will no mater do you
have yeah yeah Tommy thinks it's
negasonic Skippy teenage warhead Skippy
and then fill up I want to stress Philip
wrote this
usually I get bleeped on this show so it
was cool that that the backup believe
okay judges who's our winner oh it makes
sense I'm a phonetic spelling but uh
nope
all right who's our loser Skippy no me
sorry but we'll share that loss Tommy
you just wanna do the jokes no I but mod
is our winner is going to get to do the
in other news headlines so mod take it
away sweet
all right the first story Avengers
infinity wall has passed Jurassic world
should be the biggest summer movie of
all time
Avengers infinity Wars past Jurassic
world to be I'm stressin to be the
biggest summer of movie of all time
proving a bride that Chris Pratt I is
actually lower in his overall Chris
Hemsworth as to Chris's it's like your
Christianity was showing I would have
said Thanos game two snaps who made all
the dinosaurs disappear
what did I say I was like Tommy just
wants to do another two I'm losing my
blood again Ryan Reynolds made a
surprise appearance on a Korean singing
show singing tomorrow
dressed in disguise as a unicorn hot on
was that silver chest tomorrow or a knee
then from the music boy
[Music]
and and thus there's peace on the Korean
Peninsula do you watch the news
necessary number three Alfred Pennyworth
Batman's butler will get his own ten
episode prequel series six Network
called penny worth following Alfred in
1960s London as a British military
officer you know and a good thing it's
being directed by Joel Schumacher so we
can get those sweet nipples on the
butler suit I like it just like Deadpool
to work for it to be on that epic story
number four director Chris McKay I'm
going shot down rim is the Zac Effron it
was in talks to play Nightwing I thought
they've already got the guy no the other
guy from the Instagram video Zac Efron
Nightwing Highschool lose ago are you
doing I know you and it's not gonna pay
off well it's a real team effort
I want a bigger Sam basher well you can
always find him at same bathroom uh and
then there's me and you can find me at
fimo and then there's also miss Maude
Garrett at Lord Garrett to oust you
tease and then I think that's everybody
uh why do you have that queued up sure
fine Tommy where can we find you you can
find me at Tommy Bechtel the party zone
stop on in the Graham stop on on the
tweets find me on Facebook for pictures
of my aunts and uncles get comment down
below about any of the topics that we
discuss tweet at new rockstars about
things you want us to do like this video
and share it around if you want to if
you want to get bonus points rose but
mostly just again make sure you
subscribe to this channel for the deep
dives into the stuff you love otherwise
we'll probably just see you next week
yeah I love you so much by your blood
fund okay I love you bye
all right so cute
[Laughter]